I think it's the responsibility of
business to make products in a green way
and and make products that are perceived
to be responsible both in terms of the
products themselves and how the company
behinds them operate companies can only
go so far in terms of of getting people
to eat well or exercise or or not abuse
their bodies in any number of different
ways and not abuse the planet as well
but there's a lot that companies can do
companies have tremendous communications
cloud and and a lot of companies i
talked to say well it could cut
customers and demanding that we're not
hearing it from the consumer will
consumers buy lots of things that they
didn't demand it's things that we make
available to them that we convince them
that they want and so there's an
opportunity here to to help promote a
lifestyle that's a more environmentally
responsible probably healthier for
families and communities as well but
they have to as I said be better
products or perceived to have some value
beyond that now people want to change
without changing when it comes to change
people love the noun hate the verb right
so it's very hard for people to really
you know want to make dramatic changes
in their life unless they see some
specific and improvement for themselves
so the unfortunate part but it is the
reality is that when it comes to quote
unquote saving the planet it's really
about what's in it for me me first and
then the planet so I'm not going to make
a big change in my life I'm not going to
switch brands I'm not going to go out of
my way pretty much sir I'm not going to
pay any more for the privilege of doing
the right thing I have to get something
out of that and maybe just pride maybe
and some people do that maybe it's a
it's a badge of honor or maybe it's just
you know self-satisfaction but in more
cases not it has to be some financial or
performance or other kind of benefit so
I think to the extent that companies can
help us understand what those benefits
are and can in fact design products and
services that aren't just greener but
better there will be opportunity
here one of the other realities is that
companies aren't very good at
storytelling around this stuff County
steering really good at storytelling in
general but when it comes to the
environment storytelling takes on a
particularly important part of this
because when you think about what we're
talking about here on one hand we're
talking about incredible complex geeky
scientific technical issues about which
even the experts don't always agree and
on the other hand we're talking about
our bodies and our and our families and
our kids in our community in our future
and our planet so its head and heart
right and if you've ever spent any time
talking to anyone about this you know
that if you go one millimeter too far in
either direction you lose your audience
or either you know to over your head I
don't know what you're talking about
this is just too complex for me or
you're too sort of California whoo-whoo
around this and you lose your audience
into your case and so storytelling is
how we integrate head and heart it's how
we we take complex things and make them
accessible companies haven't done a very
good job of doing that you know there's
this line that's just you know I just
say Kermit you'll know exactly what the
line is it's it ain't that easy being
green is the song lyric that Kermit sang
you know how long ago that was 41 years
ago 1969 it's older than Earth Day and
and that still represents the state of
the art of green marketing I get press
releases every day come-ons pitches
advertising slicks all kinds of things
from copywriters and ad agencies and PR
firms and the like and I know that the
person they contain that Kermit line
there's some version of it is it isn't
that easy and I know that the copy
writer who wrote that thinks that she or
he is the most clever person for having
come up with that and the fact is it's
tired it's it's hackneyed and it's not
even true it's not that easy being green
it actually takes some work so we need
to find better ways to communicate and
tell those stories
you know in the in the 1990s during the
dot-com boom of the late 90s there was
this this axiom that that content is
king that those companies that had
content would be the ones that ruled the
universe in the new connected digital
internet world and a lot of those
companies most of them went away and it
turns out that it wasn't content that
was king it was context context is king
and if you look at the companies that
survived the ebays and Google's and
Yahoo's and and and others those are the
ones that didn't craigslist and those
are the firm's that make sense of all
this massive information out there they
give it some kind of context i'm a
bility to organize and find things and
and have things elevate to what things
are the most important of all and
relative to your interests or relative
to that of your friends and and so in
context is what's missing here in terms
of company storytelling they want to
know that something is good or better
for the environment they went out of the
context because if you say well this is
green and therefore you should buy it
how green and what is it really green or
has it is it part of is it the only
issue this product has is that is your
you company as a company trying to say
you're green as a result of that so I
think people want to know that you
understand as a company what your
environmental issues are they want to
know that you know your problems that
you've done your homework and then they
want to know that you're on the case
that you're doing something about that
that you've got some plan in some kind
of commitment and that you have some and
that you're talking about this openly
and authentically not just waving your
arms and and quoting Kermit and saying
hey we green but actually putting it
into context and giving it some some
sense of this is what we're doing right
now but this is part of a journey that
we're on this is part of a long-term
proposition we're not claiming that by
doing this we're a green company I think
that people who who the companies that
can demonstrate that they understand
their problems from an environmental
perspective have a plan in place to do
something about it even if its long-term
and imperfect and never gets them to be
perfectly good which no company really
ever will be and are talking about that
openly and authentically will be in
I laid a foundation for being able to
make specific environmental claims and
and put out environmental products and
talk about environmental issues in a
credible way and not and even to
innovate and fail and still land on
their feet and not be charged as green
washers or as phonies or just ignored
and I think that companies don't lay
that foundation they don't create that
context that they need in order to make
specific environmental claims